wow
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
finally [__] Friday Friday
sick of the week I'm sick of the week
for sure maybe you're staying in maybe
you're going out
either way we're gonna start the night
off with uh
a little bit of vodka and cranberry yeah
we're having vodka cranberry today
yep and um
we can review the week we can talk about
whatever you guys want to talk about
or um
or just everybody's starting to filter
in now you know how it goes we always
end up talking about like some crazy
yeah we'll talk about some crazy [__] I
did want to mention though that I heard
the news today that uh Andy Rourke of
the Smiths has passed away he was only
59 years old and then I was thinking to
myself he's not the one that was like a
real bad drug addict right that was that
was Mike Joyce was it not I don't like
that was on heroin or whatever I don't
know those guys too well but I don't
know
yeah yeah
um but yeah he's he apparently died
which like I said and he was actually
like younger than I thought which was
crazy but yeah I saw some posts earlier
that like Johnny Marr had posted about
him
but yeah that's pretty pretty sucky
uh Zach says can we talk about how pole
dancing is apparently considered a form
of exercise
oh yeah it's hard it was I was gonna say
um you know yeah it sounds kind of funny
but uh pole dancing is absolutely not as
easy as it looks and especially like all
the strippers and stuff like that that
have to do that in like those [__]
huge spike heels and all that other kind
of stuff [__] I can't even walk in
those so um anybody that because I have
a pair yeah
um but every time I walk in them I'm
like going like that like a baby deer
yeah yeah she never really wore them
long enough to get adjusted to him yeah
but uh you can I think I wore him out
one time yeah and manage to not break my
neck yeah but it was a it was a real
unpleasant experience
they look nice though yeah
no I've actually seen you can go on
YouTube and see uh
um challenges where they're trying to
take these bodybuilders and try to get
them to do some of those pole dancing
exercises like just hold themselves
straight out and just call climb up it
with one one leg and those dudes are
[__] strong man they bench [__]
600 pounds no they can't do it yeah but
then a little 120 pound girl can do it
yeah yeah
it's like a type of gymnast gymnast type
thing you know I mean I did gymnastics
when I was a kid
and uh yeah that is absolutely it's a
different kind of strength I think but
you know it's definitely much harder
than people give it credit for you have
to be strong and Light
at the same time yeah
and um
and yeah and you have to have real good
balance
yeah
which I did before my ears went to [__]
when I was a teenager
I used to be really good at gymnastics I
took ballet and I took um gymnastics and
I was like the best one in my class I
was like super flexible
you know I mean I could do like back
bends I could do all that kind of [__]
but you know I saw one uh
bodybuilder that you know the dancer
just says look grab it here put your
foot on that side of the pole and just
looking
just hang your other leg down just do it
and he's like and I'm like I'm thinking
he should be able to do that he couldn't
do it yeah because it doesn't sound
difficult when you say it he's like God
damn you know he's a 240 pound all
muscle but 240 pounds and it's just
his muscle mass wasn't trained for that
kind of exercise you know what I mean he
was just trained for just raw power and
to be big yeah and uh that's not what
that type of exercise calls for
yeah it's completely different yeah a
lot of muscular control and balance and
stuff yeah yeah
like I said it is and if you're
lightweight it would help you
because you're not fighting the force of
gravity all right for the weight of your
own body yeah I mean that's why I mean
you never really see like uh ballet
dancers with like big old Badonkadonk or
anything like that no they're usually
like pretty trim yeah
yeah and that's the thing too is that
you know especially ballet dancers like
they have to kind of get flung around by
other dancers and lifted and stuff like
that so it's always better if they don't
weigh all that there's there's a whole
porn
subcategory of flexible just call
flexible and it's all those little
Russian ballerina and Russian
contortionist girls which I think it's
the same thing I think I think
contortion is a part of maybe maybe you
need that for ballet I don't know
but they'll put little masks on so you
don't know who they are but they can
just like and do all these [__] just
crazy contortions man and they're not
they're nude half the time but there's a
lot of times no sex going on it's just
dudes getting off on the fact that a
girl can just bend herself and just
spread herself yeah it is hot it is hot
it's like God damn that how is that
possible like a girl Bend herself
backwards Arch her back so so hard that
she can put her back or her head in
between her legs but the the ass crack
side that was just unbelievable I mean I
couldn't believe that somebody could do
that
man if the girls could eat themselves
out they'd probably never leave the
house oh those girls could easily do it
that's what I'm saying
that one girl could almost do it
backwards right
in other words she could Bend her head
back so far she could set her head on it
on it on her ass
yeah while she was standing on two legs
yeah I've seen some girls do that and
then just arms straight out like that
it's just like that's [__] incredible
I was never that good on it but when I
was younger like this is when I was like
for like pre-puberty or right before I
like right around the time I was going
through puberty
um I could actually you know I could
just go from a standing position and
just go whoop then just go like do a
background like that I used to be able
to do that and I used to could do like
hand Springs and backflips and all that
kind of stuff if you had time you could
get back into that I probably could yeah
I have [__] flexible women sexy man
I know I was like well like I said I
used to be able to I'm still not I'm not
that unflexible anymore like you know
I'm older now and I haven't like really
practiced it but I can still kind of
like yeah I need to get into yoga yeah I
was thinking maybe I should do that like
you can't do it that full-time job
though that's that's the problem I don't
have time no there's no time okay
there's a commute that kills you it is
yeah
they did let me go from 7 30 to 4 30
then so I'd get home an hour or like
half an hour earlier which actually does
make a big difference
which is kind of nice because I was
always getting there like early anyway
so they were like well you might as well
just
come in and clock in and then you can
leave half hour earlier and I was like
yeah that's a good idea this tablet's
giving me problems I think I'm gonna
have to get the other one it keeps
losing its connection I'll be back in a
second Camp guy said Mikhail barishnikov
if my Cod piece was that large I'd jump
and leap about too
[Laughter]
Abraham he was very big in the 80s was
it he was in that movie wasn't he white
knights was that what that movie was
called
so I don't think it's okay maybe I'm
crazy but I thought that that was the
first thing that popped in my head and
that's usually the right thing but not
always
John Robertson said uh hey Jenny I
started reading a new book called
something more than Night by Kim Newman
oh I've read some some stuff by Kim
Newman
it's about Boris Karloff and Raymond
Chandler teaming up to solve
Supernatural mysteries in Hollywood
holy [__] what is it uh that sounds like
it was exactly written for me what's it
called it's called something more than
night about Boris Karloff and Raymond
Chandler teaming up to solve
Supernatural mysteries in Hollywood see
that kicks ass I really like the little
Sub sub genre of we're taking some at
like real and or fictional characters
from history and putting them together
and they solve crimes like that's pretty
cool like I think like so far my
favorite book like that is drude
obviously by Dan Simmons which is about
uh Charles Dickens and Wilkie Collins
but um he did another one that was like
man what was it it was Sherlock Holmes
who I know isn't real but it was
Sherlock Holmes like in that Universe he
was a real person and wait who the [__]
was it was Sherlock Holmes and a real
guy like a real writer but I can't
remember who it was right now I just got
a message from um Michael from a starry
night uh-oh what did he says there's two
sentences the first one was bro
yeah that's Michael all right yeah
please tell Jenny to check her email I'm
hoping she can help me with a poster
okay I just said okay but she's on show
right now
he's one he's that bad there man he
wants you to [__] do the [__] right
[__] now because he I know how he is
okay he thumbs up he's coming back but
yeah bro
yeah yeah when he wants me he [__]
he's nice as [__] if I'm at the show he
tells like he doesn't know me
I go to the other bedrooms this [__]
pretend like he doesn't know me for
these other people they start Michael
get up [__] get the [__] back over here
that's pretty funny yeah he goes thank
you beautiful he called me
if you guys don't know starry night it's
a good band I helped him get assigned in
their early years [__] our friend
Imani Jenny worked for Imani she was
making all these damn black metal
[__] album covers
we were at dinner with Imani she's from
New York and she's like uh Tom what's
your favorite Tom what's your favorite
Orlando band and I said you like the
best one or my favorite one in Florida
band and that's a starry night's the
best band in Florida she went out and
[__] signed him yeah yeah then they
got onto a Better Label later on they
got on [__] uh uh dance Macabre no
what was uh yeah or something like that
yeah this one in Germany I think yeah
because they played in Germany and stuff
like that yeah they're actually bigger
in Europe than they are here
but uh they got three albums out that
third one's good too
yeah they're all good yeah they're all
good that's the thing though it's like
I'm just you know I I've been working
all day and I don't really feel like
working anymore tonight so I'm not gonna
yeah let him stammer
I'm not doing it right now I'm not doing
it right now
um you know I might do it tomorrow but
you know that's the thing it's like I
just kind of feel like now it's I only
have weekends to do stuff and it's like
I feel like we have to cram everything
in over the weekends and I'll have time
to do anything yeah especially if I have
like freelance [__] which
I don't well I have a couple things
which are like pending but I don't know
like what they're gonna entail because
I'm still waiting for more details about
them you know what I mean yeah so it's
that kind of thing
but at this point I'm like look I've
been at work all day I don't really feel
like
I don't want to check my I want to be
one of those people that like doesn't
check their email after like 6 p.m or
something like that I'm just like leave
me alone I'm trying to have a [__]
yeah I'm trying to have a [__]
evening or like a weekend you know what
I mean because I don't really get that
falling behind on porn production too
well I mean it's yeah we we did some
like last week but you know it didn't it
just it didn't come out as good as we
wanted but that's okay like you know
we'll get it all done yeah I know you
know yeah and honestly like we were
saying before it's probably like going
to be better like the streaming is
probably going to be more yeah where the
money is yes but we do have to have some
videos like as yeah you gotta have
street cred yeah like that so we did
want to have like like a bunch of videos
made like before we did the streams yeah
although I do want to start streaming
soon because I you know I kind of feel
like that's probably where the money is
I got my new Jack strap too
yeah it's it's looking it's looking
lovingly and the other jock straps in
the closets
the label had the pride flag on the back
of it oh yeah so if you guys if you buy
a jockstrap it's gay no yeah all right
well I mean I I sent a picture of that
[__] to [__] Zach I said Zach look I
got jockster but it's gay
and I said now Jay's trying to Peg me
and it's actually what else is new
exactly you better learn how to clean
out
[Laughter]
I said
just send it to me at work like on my
phone it's black and red man yeah it's
cool yeah and um so he he was like oh
look it came today or something like
that and I said yeah and I said we're
gonna make a video of you twerking in
that
I was [__] laughing man so then yeah
like last night he got out the shower
and he's like I'm gonna put these on so
he put him on and he's like turned
around he's like shaking his love it's
like so funny I got some too he tried it
Jenny couldn't resist that [__]
no straps in the back just cupping you
and everything around your little round
boots
oh you know you know you wanted to from
the very start and from the very like
moment that you brought it up
hahaha
yeah John Smith said as opposed to a
heterosexual trash trap I mean I always
thought I always thought that
that jock straps well I mean when I
thought about it at all which I never
have but the jock straps were probably
pretty gender neutral but you know yeah
right there yeah [__] right there
that [__] right there is designer and
everything and it's just you got the
straps in the back and everything
you'll just have to imagine
just have to imagine that [__] well I
mean when we get all the videos done you
want yeah because I'm sure that we'll
probably have some videos with you
wearing that
because you're gonna well and also easy
access
for pegging no
yes
look at that little triangle man that
can't hold all of me in there
I'm wrapping [__] around it's [__]
coming up around the waistband to hide
it mushroom head in the back
sexy as [__] I get all kinds of [__]
gay fan mail on that one
I mean see that's the thing I think that
we can really we can appeal to all
demographics
humor is going to be a big part of it
man you guys got to see some of this
[__] the way it was edited and me
looking at the camera going oh foreign
like me and him because I said well I
want you here when I edit it so like you
can help me out or like give me ideas or
you know if you don't like something and
you want me to take it out or something
like that like oh I don't look good from
the angle or whatever so it's like so
we're sitting there editing it and
there's one [__] great moment
where
uh you know like he's behind me or
whatever and he turns around look at the
camera
and I was like oh my God what a
hilarious moment and so I I was just
like like too close up on his face and I
did like a sound effects
I feel like every time I watched it
everywhere I would like crack up all
over again yeah and then like aftermath
I'm looking at the camera going goddamn
God damn
it's like shakers yeah
it was like so funny but it's like just
what we were editing I'm like oh my God
this is awesome well well the thing
about it is that I think that that's one
thing that's gonna make our stuff maybe
Stand Out is this you know it's because
it's kind of funny like you know what I
mean it's not so funny that it's like
you know not right yeah it's not like
that but it's just kind of like I think
that a little bit of humor will go like
a long way because I think a lot of
other I mean how much well not in
everything though do you have well yeah
not not in everything no no in some
things some some some situations yeah
I just think that would be really funny
well because one of the one of the
funniest things that you showed me was
that girl that does she just does solo
stuff but she always just says it with
dildos but she makes it think she makes
you think there's somebody else in the
thing because she always like does she
talks and she's like talking and she
does like all these different characters
yeah and then like you know smacking
herself in the face with a dildo and
she's like crying and stuff but it's
like she's obviously and the titles of
them are [__] hilarious yeah so it's
like entitled enough to get you I know
the title is just like it's so funny
Lexi black yeah with a bunch of x's on
it and I was like that girl that girl
knows what she's doing she's on um
I don't remember what platform it was
names of videos [__] like
I don't have the rent but I got a mouth
right it's like [__] like that uh the
fat [__] can't pay uh [__] you know
pay for the bus that just anything you
know she's just trying to weasel her way
through these situations using her mouth
and she and she makes like really funny
like trailers yeah like so you can see
you can watch the like a sample like
before you buy the video yeah and it's
like the way she edits them is like
really really funny and like I like yeah
long eyelashes tears running she's not
fat she's not fat she called herself fat
I know she calls herself yeah long
eyelashes tears [__] like smackers
it's like [__] up lipsticks
[__] up lipstick
um you could tell she's having a good
time I think that's what we're playing
talking to people that aren't there
um now she's not the same one that
dreads this because we were see you
showed me that one because you were
showing me like all the Velma cosplay
ones because there's like a [__] ton
yeah and this way he's like you gotta
see this one this one's hilarious so the
girl in play it wouldn't really play
through the whole yeah but like I got
the gist yeah so like she had dressed up
his film this was like a different a
different girl I think yeah she had
dressed up his Velma but she had this
whole
scenario where she had dropped her
glasses and was looking for them because
you know if you've seen this original
Scooby-Doo cartoons like she was always
Velma was always [__] losing her
glasses and she was blind to [__]
without them the idea is Mystery help me
find your glass find my glasses yeah
make sure we help you find my glasses
all kinds of [__] [__] and then like
she can't see and then like there's a
dick in her face it's just a dildo
and I was like oh my God that's [__]
yeah she's I I can't remember her name
off top of my head but she's just beyond
stacked she's
got it
kind of a little waste and a giant
fake booty probably and just huge
implants and trying to remember what her
name was yeah I don't know because we
because we kind of scrolled everything
exaggerated because Tom's like holy [__]
look at all these Velma cosplay yeah
there's like a video there's like a
million of them that one is one that
kind of stands out I forgot what her
name was though there's a [__] ton of
Wednesday ones too and like after that
show came out because everybody's trying
to cash in you know yeah there's a
couple good with those there's a couple
good ones of those
um there was one I was trying to show
you but it wouldn't load yeah but she
was good because she was a tried
stripper she knew how to dance she had
to put on a real [__] good dance do
the whole thing did she do the actual
like Wednesday no no she did her own
thing it was a stripper dance okay maybe
that [__]
booty shaking and twerking and [__] and
then getting up on a couch and going
solo and [__] blowing dildos and butt
plugs and [__]
she was hot and um braids you know
um she's probably about I don't know
22-23 and she kind of looks like that
girl a little bit right
like the original girl or the girl that
plays her on the Netflix on the Netflix
oh okay but she's I think blue eyed or
green eyed I think that girl that played
Wednesday on the Netflix show is gonna
be in the Beetlejuice sequel like as I
think she's supposed to be Lydia's
daughter because I think they got Winona
Ryder back to be okay like so she's
gonna be the mom because Winona Ryder
has been on stranger things you know
that right like she plays a mom on
Stranger Things
so
Zach's telling me I need to get those
injections to get my ass bigger you know
what those injections are man that's
[__] damn tires it's tire sealant
yeah that's probably not something you
should be injecting into your butt um
I like your butt the way it is anyway
it's good just like it is I don't think
he needed
it's perks I do leg day
yeah yeah
laughs
uh Dean mccaskill has obviously not been
here in a while said hey you two holy
[__] man it's been a minute working out
much
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah how long has it been since
you've been it's been a while since
you've been here huh yeah yeah I don't
remember how long it's good yeah it has
been a while
but yeah he's all
it's like well not only that you've
you've been working out but you also
shaved your head you grew up you grew a
little Ming the merciless beard yeah or
a little Mirror Universe Spock yeah I
look different now yeah you look like a
big sky look I look at how I look at
your [__] five years ago man and
I [__] was like damn I can't believe
I looked that bad you didn't look bad I
looked five years ago I looked bad
I thought it looked bad I didn't thank
you I was looking real doughy looking
doughy and weak looking
didn't like it didn't like it that's why
I got rid of it yeah age starts creeping
up with you well yeah that kind of
happens Shawn Smith said Mary Universe
town you are kind of like Mary
University yeah Trend made me the Mirror
Universe Tom
and I was mirrored to begin with
yeah so it was like so it was like it
was like that endless incursion thing
yes or endless recursion or whatever
yeah where's like a mirror reflection
and a mirror reflection yeah and it gets
worse and worse like yeah
hahaha
I became the goblin man all the [__] you
were on I know Spiderman Spiderman
Spiderman
why walk the path of the hero the people
just want to see the only thing that
they want to see from a hero is to see
him fall why bother yeah yeah
so nihilistic yeah
save the one you love or suffer the
little children remember that flick
remember that scene that was like it's
been a long time since I've seen it
yeah that was that was when the Goblins
telling Spider-Man you never know what a
psycho was gonna say you never know when
you call it no he called him uh
I didn't call him a psycho
basically he says you never know when
somebody will show up and put you in a
difficult position you know uh in like a
no win no lose situation and he's got
he's holding the damn bus full of
children in one hand and he's holding
Mary Jane in another hand and he drops
them at the same time he goes Jews you
know remember that
save the children or save Mary Jane yeah
I don't remember what what did he do did
he say he saved everything he saved them
both yeah
because he's [__] Spiderman yeah of
course these courses yeah he was
shooting webs and [__] they shoot whips
yeah Goblin should have thought of that
oh yeah damn well there goes that lesson
he didn't care
I was on that performance drug he's not
the same [__] he was on shred and he had
a [__] power glider and a [__]
body armor and use the psychological
warfare on people that was willing to
throw in it right yeah I love well yeah
and he's tweaking out talking to the
goblin the Goblin's talking to him it's
kind of like something out of Venom
going crazy
yeah
Dean says uh uh you look good too sister
well thank you very much
[Laughter]
John Smith said is there a cave with a
giant Tom Star Trek Deep cut uh Cave
with a giant with a giant Tom oh I don't
know what he's talking about cave with
John Tom
there was a cave that had a giant in
Star Wars in Star Trek
I remember that I don't remember that
either where are we talking like
original Star Trek are we talking about
because that's really the only one that
I'm super super familiar with like
you're probably familiar with Enterprise
and all that because you watched all
that but I didn't I watched Enterprise
but it was a long time ago yeah original
series I'm more up on that because I've
seen that a bunch of times but the other
ones I'm not as familiar with Next
Generation I watched it it was good yeah
I think I saw the most of that once I
don't think I saw any of Voyager
Voyager was pretty good Captain Janeway
I liked it chicote and all that oh John
Smith said there's a giant Spock in the
Animated Series oh I didn't see the
animated you know what we should watch
the Animated Series because I remember
seeing it when I was a kid and I
remember it being pretty good yeah it
was it was actually the same writers and
everything yeah yeah and didn't they
have like most of the same the cast so
it wasn't like was in it and everything
yeah I'll watch anything with Leonard
Nimoy in it he's awesome yeah
so yeah that's that's another thing we
should watch and we should probably
write that now
I should probably write that down Star
Trek Animated Series yeah because that's
something we could I mean they did kind
of
tune it down tune it a little bit
towards kids but it's it was good yeah
I remembered it I remembered liking it
about like Johnny Quest
yes I used to dig Johnny Yes too
Star Trek animated
I used to like all those old cartoons
man what's the one we were talking about
it wasn't Johnny Quest but what was the
one that had the um the Triceratops with
the thing that like in the shmoo and all
that what was that one it was called The
Herculoids that's right yeah I don't
know why I always forget that name yeah
because it made a big impression but I
don't know why I don't remember the name
of it
yeah The Herculoids were uh
some people from Earth that ended up on
a crash landing on a planet
it was real barbaric had all kinds of
barbaric aliens it was kind of like the
dinosaur times yeah it was like a
scientist and his wife and his two kids
yeah I remember that and they made
friends with some of the aliens like the
two [__] gleep and gloop it wasn't it
gleaping gloop they're like two yeah
yeah they were smooth and then they had
uh they were my favorite they had this
big thing that looked like a [__]
rock gorilla yeah that's right
forgot what his name was
and then they had a Triceratops with a
bunch of legs on the bottom
rocks yeah
then they had a dragon that they could
fly around on and it shot lightning
bolts out of its eyes I got one of those
big deal yeah
John Robertson said the last Voyage of
the Demeter looks like a good horror
movie if you guys have seen the trailer
yeah I saw the trailer um a few weeks
ago and I'm actually really excited to
see that because I kind of always
thought I was like why do Dracula
adaptations always leave out like the
part that happened on the ship like when
they would bring a Dracula over to
England this movie is about that yeah so
I was like well see there's a new angle
on the Dracula thing that nobody has
done yet I'm trying to remember what
that big rock gorilla from The
Herculoids was called yeah what the [__]
was it I was thinking that it was struck
an Ookla the muck but I think that was
an off of I think that was Thunder or
the Barbarian is is where yeah I
remember a character called Ookla
I think there was thunder on the
Barbarian sidekick
but it was for some reason I want to say
Ookla the muck but it's not that
some you guys can Google it the Hercules
yeah
that kind of sounds like maybe something
we could do at some time this weekend
we'll go we'll go down the rabbit review
the herculites we'll get on the rabbit
hole of like weird old that was old
Hannah parts that was all was that
handlebar yeah Hannah Barbera old Hannah
Barbera stuff recycled a lot of the same
footage over and over yeah they did so
they didn't have to make as much stuff
so it seemed real repetitive to an adult
Ben said his name was igu yeah I think
it was igu or igu yeah IG yeah what was
the name of the damn triceratops and the
Dragon
and then I think the other one was gleep
and gloop were the two schmooz I thought
yeah that sounds right yeah there was a
big one and a little one yeah they were
like little wait couldn't they smoosh
together they could do uh they didn't
make one big one okay
they could make things together they
could become any shape that they wanted
and they were friendly and they bounced
around they just looked like egg-shaped
pieces of Play-Doh with [__] eyes Ben
says zoc and tundro that's right zoc zoc
was the [__] uh was the [__]
Dragon tongro was the [__]
Triceratops that they could ride around
they run him around it was actually it
was like a cross between a an elephant a
triceratops and a [__] Rhino yeah I
remember him being kind of rhino but he
was clearly supposed to be up to
Triceratops I didn't think he was all
that big though I thought he was just
kind of like this is big no it's the
size of a rhino
okay easily well I was thinking well
yeah but I mean I was thinking that like
not big in the sense of like a [__]
Kaiju or no or Dragon size or anything
like that I was thinking you could ride
on him like a horse or something even
the dragon wasn't that big yeah yeah but
um you know Dragon was the size of a
Tyrannosaurus Rex maybe you know 25 feet
long maybe 30 feet I don't know long and
slender tail on it and um
but no the uh what was the name of the
thing again [__] I forgot its name
already not eat not igoo igu not him the
[__] try no Tundra yeah Tundra was
about the size of a [__] rhino
or an elephant a rhino probably well
Rhino's a lot smaller than an elephant
not a lot
significantly the size of an Indian
Elephant maybe yeah Indian elephants are
smaller yeah African like elephants are
much bigger Rhino is way big enough way
bigger yeah it's big enough to [__] up
your day yeah sure knock the car over
yeah
they got a video of them ramming cars
[__] your car boom yeah [__] smash a
car up [__] yeah
[__]
uh Zach is talking about some cartoons
from when he was a kid and this is very
funny because you're a lot younger than
us so I actually remember I did I didn't
like you know I was older obviously so I
didn't see these but I did see some
episodes um he's talking about Ed Edd
and Eddie and um uh Hey Arnold and I did
actually see a few episodes of that but
like I said I was a little bit older
because I have younger siblings who were
um
kind of the age to watch that stuff so I
did kind of like see it so I did see
some of those
I remember there was like a lot of stuff
around Nickelodeon around that time like
Rugrats and all that kind of stuff I
remember I remember liking Rugrats
actually
uh Ben said another good show from
ancient history was the dungeon the
Dragons cartoon yeah I vaguely remember
that one I vaguely remember that one too
yeah yeah I I didn't really I didn't
like it I think from what I remember I
thought that it kind of made a joke of
the game because I took the game pretty
seriously back back when I was in
seventh eighth grade you know I was like
oh they're making a mockery of it
um because we thought that was some
serious [__] as you're basically dealing
with Satanism almost nerd yeah just
kidding but um
trying to think of what else cartoons
that I thought were good back then
um
there was a series of
animated books that were going around my
Military Academy
if I can even call it elf Quest we found
one of those yeah yeah we had some of
those it's kind of like a
inspired by Dungeons and Dragons and
inspired by [__] Lord of the Rings
and it's just about
a tribe or the whole world is populated
by humans and elves and magic [__] you
know magic [__]
but during this time humans are humans
are basically kind of like Neanderthal
you know they're primitive they have
fire I think
but they're more like cavemen you know
and the the elves are a little more
advanced they're kind of like at the
level of like a Native American Indian
but instead of riding around on horses
they rode around on wolves
and I I remember the animation or the
drawings looking pretty good for the
time I have been a long time since I've
seen it
somebody I remember I mentioned it on an
earlier show a couple years back and
somebody Googled it and said yeah it
doesn't look that good
but at the time we thought it looks
pretty good I mean it probably looked
good in comparison in comparison to
other things that were going on in the
very uh early 80s
you know maybe 81 but might have been as
as late as 79 around that time
it was just part of like the fantasy
genre
and like the little hobby stores where
you'd buy Dungeons and Dragons and the
lead figurines to paint and for the game
and and they had little
magazines that they were selling their
comics and stuff
and that was one of them and we I had I
had most of the I think I had like a
first five
every good
and uh they had like one of the one of
the
one of the characters of little elf
woman
and uh everybody had a crush on her we
just thought that girl was so cute it
was just a drawing
she was blue I think remember correctly
like a Smurf
but she uh
had big hair
almost like a goth big old [__] goth
haircut if I remember correctly was like
bags and [__] like
tight
foreign
bell bottoms like made out of leather
and [__] with a [__] daggers and
swords and probably just probably just a
bikini top knowing the way we would way
we like [__] back then well knowing the
way they used to draw yeah yeah and I
think it was like still they still kind
of dropped that way part of the story
was like her and her sister and these
wolves that they used to ride around and
then they're fighting humans and they
fight all kinds of [__] and and um then
she gets a boyfriend who's a [__] elf
and he's like another kind of Elf I
think it's like a Wood Elf or something
wood elf and a straw elephant yeah they
had different kinds of them they had
Subterranean ones you know like Dro
and like I I don't think from real quick
I think she was like a desert Elf or
something it's been a long time since
I've
since I've read it
speaking of blue people we should
probably look on some of those cosplay
porn and see if there's any Smurfette
ones I don't think she was blue
I don't think she was blue I I that
would be hilarious yeah
I think they were just regular flesh
time getting gang banged by all the
other Smurfs for some reason I'm
thinking blue she might have had blue
hair oh it's either blue or white hair
I think I know what you're talking about
I think she might have been blue with
like light blue go look let me go look
I'm gonna go
uh Zach says it's weird I watched a lot
of Rugrats as a kid but I was never into
that show a lot of it freaked me out
more than anything it was kind of a
weird show uh now that I think about it
uh it's like there are several episodes
that always show up on those nightmare
fuel cartoon lists for people yeah I can
see that
I can see that
uh Ben said the Wolves that's right they
had every Trope in there yeah that's it
right there
yeah I remember that we had we had a
couple of those
we had a couple of those yeah
I don't remember which one we had but it
was remember the one with white hair
yeah yeah
um the thing is this went on for a long
time I don't remember exactly what
what version I had
that's basically the way the art looked
yeah I remember that they had big hair
and [__]
John Smith said while Papa Smurf films
it yeah see Papa Smurf would be filming
it and then all the because you know
everybody was thinking even the 80s I
was a little kid and I'm just like one
girl Smurf and a whole bunch of boys
Smurfs what the [__] is going on there
also I used to think it was weird that
she had
only one dress well she didn't only have
one dress she just had many dresses that
all looked exactly the same it almost
looks like a damn orgy going on there
it does kinda yeah he's guessing one of
them the other ones going you let me get
in there and then let me get it
yeah back around they got the wolf
give me some of that yeah yeah it's like
all right
[Laughter]
sexy [__]
they're elves they can do yeah they can
do what they want
they're not humans that's how you get
away with that kind of stuff yeah
I mean I'm sure there's lots and lots of
it the artist looking at it now the
artist's okay
yeah it's okay
I don't think it would compare to the
day see look at that's some [__]
suggestive [__] uh yeah a little bit
yeah
that's some suggestive [__] well you
can't really see it because it's kind of
Whited out and then the dogs are nipping
at the heels I was gonna say even the
dogs even the dog the dogs are involved
man all kind of shots
man the [__] early 80s were the [__]
man
laughs
man no wonder your parents were like
thinking you were worshiping look at
that
uh uh all right yeah yeah it's all
polyamorous polyamorous
laying laying around in a big cluster
a cuddle puddle yeah it's a catapult
oh man that says Smurfs are all asexual
she was probably in a feminine
cross-dresser to be honest maybe I mean
I don't know it just seemed weird that
she was the only one that had a dress on
all the other ones just like all the
other Smurfs they didn't have shirts did
they just had pants they just had like
those little white pants right and then
they didn't have anything on their tops
I don't remember
I don't think they had anything on the
tops I always thought it was like really
really weird that
on the Smurfs that Gargamel was trying
to catch them because he would he was
gonna eat them right wasn't gonna eat
them
I think so I'm pretty sure he was gonna
eat them
if I remember correctly
I guess they're a delicacy where he
comes from
Smurfs and then remember there was that
other show that was kind of like I don't
want to say it was like a knockoff
necessarily because they added their own
thing going on but remember the Snorks
who were kind of they weren't even
really kind of like Smurfs but they
didn't they live underwater they lived
underwater and they had like little
blowhole type situation like in their
heads like or something I don't I only
saw that a couple of times I don't
remember that much about it
um Ben said he wanted to make a potion
out of them or something didn't he yeah
I thought he wanted to eat them but
maybe I could be like it's been a long
time I don't think I ever saw it I don't
think I ever watched The Smurfs yeah
John says that I think gargamall wanted
Smurf magic or something yeah he had
that CAT um Azrael was the name of the
cat I remember that
yeah but yeah
uh let me see
I I don't know I I thought he wanted to
eat them but I don't know Zach says if
you wanted to make the big bucks you
should cosplay as anime characters yeah
I know it's just I don't really know
anything about that and it's like I
would feel a lot more
I don't know I guess I would just feel
like a lot more comfortable cosplaying
is like stuff that I knew what it was
because I don't really know hardly
anything about anime and so I would kind
of feel like uh I would kind of feel
like a poser you know what I mean I
think I'd rather dress up as like
Monsters or like scare like horror movie
characters or something you know
something that I was like a lot more
familiar with you know what I'm saying
if I'm gonna do any kind of Cosplay like
I said I don't mind doing like we were
talking about doing the Star Trek kind
of [__] we talked about doing
maybe doing
um
I don't know like werewolves or some
[__] like that like some horror kind of
stuff Ben says anime porn attracts too
many weirdos
yeah I mean
I don't know and like I said I kind of
feel like there's a lot of people doing
that already
you know you want to do something that's
like popular but that is not that there
aren't like a zillion other people doing
it I feel like you know
what do you think I'm not thinking about
anything
well thank you that was right that was
very insightful
I mean we were talking about doing
[__]
General kala and [__] clitus
but those costumes would be expensive I
know but that's what I mean that's one
that's one of my aspirational like yeah
couples Halloween costumes I think that
would be kick ass I already got a couple
of Bane costumes yeah maybe you gotta
hook you up with a Catwoman costume
yeah or somebody said poison ivy
Catwoman Catwoman yes
you'd be like a real [__] hourglass
shaped Catwoman
with [__]
after you've done a couple Cycles yeah
that'd be good the [__] like the
newer Catwoman
was like you know the black
skin tight
it's like a leather outfit type of deal
it's a probably [__] latex with the
little goggles that look like cat eyes
yeah yeah
Ben says Tom could green up and you
could make orc massage porn yeah
yeah that might be good yeah that might
be good
you could be at work yeah
dress up as a orc
you make a good orc I think yeah orc sex
that's what we'll call the video yeah
they call it orking yeah
Jen have it to blow the orc guard so she
could get by the [__] get by the
guarded [__] Tower or whatever so I
can get in there and get ride again
rescue somebody yeah get some treasure
or something I don't know we'll have to
think of some kind of like [__] face
gotta suck his braids out
it would be funny if like you had an orc
and he had like and he had some kind of
like weird anomaly like he had two dicks
or something like that so it's like yeah
now he's got horns on it it's got a
whole ridge of horns going on the top of
it so I'm just sitting there going out
like it's like scraping up then sorry
about the [__] it's Barbed like a cat
it Orcs pork
okay
oh my God
Zach says what about a video where
Jenny's the board Queen yeah see that'd
be nice too
John Smith said something Niche dress up
as caxis from the dark Christmas yeah
that was sucks oh no that'd be cool I
would do that that would be a great
Halloween costume too yeah maybe maybe I
should do that people would mistake is
for senators
oh you know who I'd want to be if you
see original
um uh Dark Crystal movie I would like to
be
um Agra
like that she had that big um like
planetary thing like she's kind of like
a witch or whatever with the one eye
like that she was she rocked I wouldn't
mind I wouldn't mind doing that for
Halloween like I said I know what that
was well no no I'm just saying like I
wouldn't have to maybe necessarily do it
for for the show for the um for the porn
I'm just saying that that might be a
good Halloween costume
well I kind of was was Agra on the newer
Netflix series that they did in the dark
I couldn't get through it because I
didn't get through all of it so I don't
know if she was too slow because I
really like that character like from the
movie yeah and I was like how to do my
own version of snake pliskin yeah there
you go like a and and a reboot a
rebooted snake blizzard
I could do it
Ben says they used to make Superman
jokes like that where he had two penises
or weird appendages because after all
he's an alien yeah he might have like
blown Margot kidder's [__] out or
something like that
you know what I mean
well gosh Lois
I really think we're gonna have to take
this slow
can you imagine yeah I mean that's
that's a pretty freaky [__] right there
when you think about it it's all it's
all fun and games
it's all fun and games back on Krypton
he said yeah it was built for this
here on Earth okay I bust a nut it might
blow you across the room
haha
that just gave me like a really funny
like mental image yeah
so I'm gonna have to go get a very
special condom
[Music]
you have to get like a lead sheets yeah
it's kevlars
we're gonna strap it on himself to keep
it [__] attached when that [__] blows
if it Flats like a rocket
[Laughter]
punch right through her
comes out of her mouth yeah
well golly Lois I didn't know that was
gonna happen
I'm sorry
how [__] funny would that be you know
that somebody has made like a porn
version of Superman like with that
happening come on
I think I have it like I said if it
exists there's porn of it that's rule
34.
um John said yes auger was in the new
show okay I thought she might that she's
too good a character like not to bring
back and she wasn't in the movie all
that much so I kind of like that they
brought her back in anyone
Zach says uh random as [__] but I always
thought if I was a girl it would be
awesome to do the white dress from Basic
Instinct as a Halloween costume and then
well you could yes and then like not
wear any underwear and just flash your
[__] at everybody is that what you'd be
doing
Sebastian says uh I'm into that Thomas
snake and Jenny is Maggie yeah yeah we
could do that yeah she's got the tits
for that I could just like leave my
titties hanging yeah like Adrian Barbo
yeah get you that curly hair yeah
yeah yeah get that white white cocktail
dress she had
oh yeah that's right I forgot she had
that dress on because I'm trying to
think like what outfit does she have I
guess it wasn't really a cocktail dress
it's more like a slip wasn't it or a
nightie I have to go back and look at it
yeah I don't remember like exactly what
it looked like yeah it was made for
Adrian barbeau's boobs though
she was a gifted woman
yeah or at least had good bras
I love Adrian Barbara she's great I
think my favorite character that she
ever played was that was that [__] in a
creep show
I actually liked her as um the DJ in
[__] the [__] the fog yeah she's
great in that too yeah but yeah I well I
liked her in Creep Show because she
seemed to just be having the [__]
time of her life playing just like a
total [__] and it you know what I mean
yeah but the thing about it is that
some of the stuff though like when I'm
sitting there watching her and I'm just
kind of like some of the [__] she's like
yelling at her husband about I'm like
she's right though you know what I mean
like she has a right to yell at him
about that so it wasn't that much of a
[__]
but she did get eaten by the monster
spoiler alert
Mr 88 said I like Tom and Jenny just as
Tom and Jenny well I mean we like us the
way we are too but we all know about
projects we also like to yeah dress up
dress up and experiment with other
things but
I like the skexus idea though or the
awkward idea I'm gonna have to do that
for one Halloween costs a lot of money
it would but
one of these days when I'm a millionaire
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna do some [__]
Kick-Ass [__] Halloween costumes
because I thought of so many and I just
like can't afford to do them I still
want to do
what's your name from um
Dagon oh yeah like the chick at the end
of the wheelchair like the chicken the
wheelchair like with the gold crown and
like the tentacles and [__] how [__]
badass would that be like that would be
a really good costume
and I thought because I wanted to do it
when we were um
going to what the [__] is it what the
[__] is that horror convention called
uh Spooky Empire which I think is this
weekend you'd be confined to a
wheelchair though that would suck that's
all right the whole time that wheelchair
was [__] wicker and [__]
yeah it was wooden we'd have to find
something like that yeah that wheelchair
is probably hundreds of dollars to find
something like that don't don't bug me
out I know I'm just saying well it's
just that's like one of my fantasy
Halloween costumes yeah because I think
that would be okay I have to roll you
around
well I know I can do it myself I'd be
able to do it with my stuff but um but
yeah I just I because I thought it would
be so cool like just if you went like
that to a horror convention to see
actually how many people like knew who
you would know what that was yeah like
and then you'd be like hey awesome
person hey awesome person because
probably not that many people would know
but see I like that kind of thing though
I don't want to be something that like
absolutely nobody knows who it is but I
think it's like pretty cool if it's
something that's so obscure that only
like a handful of people know who it is
because then like you and the you and
those people are like best friends for
life because they actually knew who you
were
you know what I mean
um Ben says are you not familiar with
Larry niven's essay on Superman's love
life obstacles it was published in the
70s in Playboy I think
I had yeah I had never heard of that now
I'm gonna have to go find that [__]
because that's like [__] that's like
that he could be a peep and Tom he could
see right through clothes
see that's what's that's one thing you
introduce something like that yeah and
it's like I know that in the movies they
kind of made him seem like very much
like a Boy Scout like oh he would never
do such a thing and like you can't even
imagine him doing that but it's like I
don't know man it just seems like that
would be too tempting yeah you're like
well oh yeah yeah she looks good
can he like not help it because I feel
like yeah I don't think he'd be able to
help it right so it's like this is
normal vision it's not his fault that he
has x-ray vision but the thing about it
is that the weird thing is every time
they had
like they introduced the x-ray vision
Trope like in comic books and stuff it
was usually just for the purpose of
seeing through girls clothes right I
mean but you would think that if they
had real X-ray vision they would just
like see all their internal organs and
their bones and [__] which
wouldn't wouldn't be quite as sexy
unless you're into that that's not what
X-ray vision was though x-ray vision was
the ability to see whatever you wanted
to see
it was whatever technology whatever you
wanted to see if you just wanted to see
what was behind the clothes you saw that
if you wanted to see in somebody
remember because he he did that
yeah yeah Clark can't do or you know
Superman did that
he
looked at he he saw
you could tell what what her underwear
was yeah remember that and then later on
he could tell that she did not have lung
cancer yeah that's right she could he
could do it he could see whatever he
wanted so he could do like I appreciate
it yep
yeah
and uh but he looked into her lungs and
he didn't see any cancer so he could he
could see what he needed to see yeah it
was just his normal vision
Zach says idea Tom and Jenny as Tom and
Jerry
[Laughter]
size difference wouldn't be possible
yeah I'm not really small enough to be a
mouse yeah
that would be kind of funny though
John Robertson said speaking of
Halloween costumes I'm working on either
Boris Karloff from the black cat or
Vincent Price from House of Usher man
either one of those would be [__]
kick ass we did a review of I know I'm
all I don't know if you saw it but we
did a review of the black hat not too
long yeah one of my favorite movies from
that air man so good yeah hair pill seek
yeah
yeah he has badass [__] high-tech
Satanist
from the 1920s I think that was supposed
to be taking place in the 20s yeah 20s
or 30s whereas Karloff look hot as
[__] memories yeah they had sliding
doors he even had an intercom
it was all modernist and [__] he was
bragging that he had a radio yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I keep my [__] refrigerated
refrigerated
[Laughter]
they didn't
they got close but they didn't go far
enough really because
they'd never answered the question he's
got them all preserved and I guess he's
I guess they're refrigerated or somehow
preserved in these glass caskets and and
it was several women and they only
talked about one yeah who were the other
ones
extras and then like uh spares
and he says why is she like this you
know [__] Vitus Vita says why is she
like this and he goes so I can enjoy her
beauty forever
uh-huh well does that mean he's having
sex with them is this necrophilia I mean
I'm pretty sure that was the implication
yeah well you couldn't say that back
then though
but I'm pretty sure everybody that
watched it knew what they meant like oh
[__] must have been
unless we unless we're just really
perverted and have dirty minds but I
don't think so yeah he was and he was
having sex with her daughter so he had
Venus's daughter
in life and his wife in death he was
still sleeping with them both Grody
that's some [__] wild [__] man
and that set Venus over the edge he
[__] skin him alive
and then they blew up they blew up
because all the ammunition but which I
thought that sucked it was a sucky
ending
um probably the ending that they forced
them to have like look man Vitus can't
live because he's done all this bad
stuff now it was in Vengeance though
you know yeah Venus should have lived
I mean yeah he did kind of have reason
for doing yeah
[__] man [__] any dude he was a
combat veteran he was in the cool Gaul
which is like the [__] prison and
[__]
prisoner war camp and he comes out and
finds out his wife ran off with this
[__] commander and his Commander
sacrificed his whole [__] military
unit on that ground to consecrate his
new [__] satanic temple and it turns
out the wife's dead he's got the body
preserved he's probably sleeping with it
and he's got her daughter and he's
sleeping with the daughter too
no that's a little over the line you're
gonna kill that dude yeah just a little
yeah that's justifiable man that's
justifiable
you know that's manslaughter maximum
[__] uh and they'd let you off for
that they probably would they're like
bro I get it yeah they're like yeah
and um
yeah
that's a good movie uh like I said they
should have
cleaned the ending up so Venus lived but
that was see that was another thing too
and I feel like even in pre-code movies
which that was yeah
um I still think they had this weird
thing where people that did bad things
even if they were somewhat Justified
always had to get punished and like you
couldn't get away with you get away with
it like you didn't see that much right I
kind of feel like you didn't even in you
know and then once the haze code came in
I think that was explicitly spelled out
in there yeah but it's like if somebody
did bad [__] then yeah they had to be
punished for it yeah like at some point
but which is a dumb rule but
you know whatever yeah morality is
situational
sure and that's what and you can't
really do interesting stories if you're
I mean they're fictional stories so you
can't really do uh interesting stories
if you're Shackled like that I feel like
so
speaking of Boris Karloff I've been
watching if any of y'all um
are on like watch my videos over on
scare Salon Channel and I also have a
Blog too like where I write stuff I've
been very very slowly very slowly
um going through the Thriller series not
the British one because I know there was
a British one in the 70s it was called
Thriller too but it was um the American
one from early 1960s 1960 1961 it was
two seasons
um that was hosted by Boris Karloff so I
just this week watched the last five
episodes of season one so this weekend
I'm probably gonna put up a video
talking about that and the ones that I'm
the the five episodes that I watched
this week included some of the more
famous ones like pigeons from Hell which
was the um Robert E Howard story you
know the guy yeah and um also the Grim
Reaper with William Shatner which as was
actually one of my favorite episodes so
far I think that was like really really
good and also had uh lovey from this
from Gilligan's Island in it how old was
she
not that old not that old well because
Gilligan's Island when did when was
Gilligan's Island on 60s
we'll see this show was 1960 or 1961.
yeah so she was she looked about the
same like she played like an older woman
but not like an elderly yeah I don't
think she was as old as she played no I
don't think she was I think she was only
under 40s probably they kind of had her
playing like an aging yeah like a 60
year old song yeah and she was like sort
of like married to this like hot young
actor like boy toy like yeah it's like
my sixth husband or whatever it was you
know what I mean I think she was
supposed to be somebody like um who am I
thinking of who was the who was the one
that was like older was like married to
All the Young Dudes I don't know I don't
know how to remember but I think that's
usually I'm not into the Silver Screen
people I don't know I don't know who
she's supposed to be
um John Robertson says plot twist of the
century is that you know he was the one
that just said about the Boris car left
and I think yeah is that I'm only 22
years old okay but I was raised by cool
Boomers and gen xers so I know all that
you guys are talking about see yeah okay
that gives me hope for the future yep
well it's so funny because we talk about
this a lot me and Tom because when we
were growing up you know I was born in
um and he was born in 69.
so
um when we were growing up there was
still very much a generational Gap
um whereas like where our parents
we're really really not into the same
[__] as we were into and like usually I
mean my parents were pretty cool but you
know what I mean my parents were basic
basic right
but I kind of feel like in a lot of ways
because of the internet largely I think
generational differences have largely
I don't know if they've disappeared but
they're a lot more nebulous than they
used to be because I have met a lot of
people
that are like 18 19 20 that are into 80s
[__] or they're into like you know like
old Universal monster movies or into
some because the the internet makes
everything ubiquitous like and
everything's like available all at the
same time I think it matters less
um when it came out because you can just
see anything that you want to see
whenever you want to see it so it
doesn't really matter if this came out
last week or like 50 years ago it's all
there and it's all the same yeah you can
go back and watch old movies teenager
movies like breakfast club and uh
evidently a teenager of today can
understand it yeah they were like oh
yeah and it becomes part of their
culture
but that's really traditionally how
things were I mean uh cultures used to
be pretty stable over centuries
you know because they would just kind of
listen the same thing over and over
again you know that's it's and I know
they changed that much it's just that um
there was something about Boomer and
pre-broomer generations and I think the
Advent of rock and roll some people
didn't [__] go along with that and
they stayed very much something like out
of the 40s
in the 50s uh other people kind of
changed in the 60s
60s came around and I think it
bifurcated even more
and um there were just some people that
didn't like anything we liked yeah older
people didn't like anything we liked and
then if you like looked at what they
liked it was like stuff from the 40s
when I was a little kid my grandmother
she she wouldn't watch anything really
that was beyond the 40s or 50s she's
stuck in that frame you know he watched
[__] game shows
yeah in the news
but
she what reading romance novels which is
old lady porn
[Laughter]
and watching old movies from the 40s and
50s yeah
and I'm not [__] on old movies from
the 40s and 50s because I like a lot of
those too but the thing about it is that
I like good ones I yeah I like movies
from all eras yeah those movies were
just schlock they're just forgotten yeah
and well that's true of any area they
were just made on on a form on a format
they just plumped them out because there
was no TV
so they weren't all good yeah a lot of
them weren't yeah most of them I don't
think were good and the thing about it
you know people remember this is a very
common thing that people get into it's
like oh the good old days and they
remember like uh you know why don't they
make stuff like they used to or bloody
blah but the thing about it is that
stuff that came out a long time ago
that's had a lot longer time to like
winnow out of the garbage that came out
at around that same time so obviously
the [__] that's still around nowadays
that people still talk about nowadays is
the [__] that was good because we still
remember it and everybody forgets all
the shitty crap yeah you know I mean
there's some [__] that [__] was made
just black and white stuff that's just
long gone and forgotten and other [__]
that just you could watch it today just
wonderful like [__] ghost that
original Ghost and Mrs Muir we saw that
again yeah we just reviewed that not too
long ago that movie [__] holds up man
that's a badass
so fun it's a badass Love Story between
a [__] living woman and a ghost yeah
and um it turns out it turns out okay
you know [__] [__] they would they
would never make a movie like that today
not enough cast members there's not
enough [__] ESG score [__] that's
just it was just a simple tale of a
woman a single woman trying to make it
through life she was a single mom a
widow yeah
uh trying to make it through life
predatory men and [__] and a ghost helps
her through it
and he's all Gruff and rough yeah yeah I
love the man's life what was this that
was what was that guy's name what was
what was that actor's name I think it
was right there yeah yeah that was a
good movie I really like that movie like
I said I really I like old movies yeah I
like old movies they like new movies I
like all kind of movies yeah like I said
if they're good I'll watch them I don't
I don't really give a [__] and I'm not
really worried about
genre either I mean obviously you know
I'm a horror girl so if it's horror I'm
gonna watch that first but I like other
kinds of [__] too [__] you know I'll
watch dramas or musicals or hell even
westerns I'm just like I'm not hugely
into westerns but I've seen like a bunch
of ones that I liked so
I'll watch like pretty much anything if
it's good like I said
um mr88 said MTV is a microcosm of what
Jenny said I used to record videos I
liked because you could only see that
video if it was played on MTV yeah I
remember that Total Access bottleneck
yeah now you can see any video anytime
which is crazy and like I said we've met
18 year olds who are in who are super
super into like [__] that we liked like
when we were growing up like Joy
Division and Alien Sex Fiend and
Christian death and [__] like that which
is [__] crazy to me yeah they'll know
more about it than we do right sometimes
and they weren't even born yeah and then
what was funny is that they they don't
realize that they know all that [__]
because of the ease of access of today
right and that [__] was hard for us to
get back then yeah like you weren't sure
if you had all of Alien Sex fiends
albums you think you did yeah weren't
there some imports yeah it was like you
couldn't get them right yeah but now you
you would know exactly the entire disco
discography and all the other [__] but
they didn't have that there was no way
to research that back then yeah
I mean you could but it was like really
really difficult you'd have to know
where to go look for it and then right
you'd have to order a source book and it
may not be complete
ice in the early 90s I worked at a
record store in the mall and every
record store back then like in the 80s
and 90s had this giant giant catalog it
was like this big and when somebody came
in wanting something it had it
supposedly I don't think this was true
but it supposedly like had every you
know album or whatever that had ever
been released so you know if somebody
came in wanting something specifically
like you had to look it up in there and
like you could possibly order it and
like have it shipped to the store but in
practice
I don't really think they have I was a
big um Bauhaus fan and but I had only up
until recently up until the Advent of
[__] YouTube
I had only seen three of the videos I
had only seen she's in parties
mask
and [__]
um Stardust yeah there's the only three
videos I had seen and I'd only seen them
maybe like once a piece or twice maybe
once or twice a piece because you
depended on other [__] to play
it yeah
yeah they would play it on 120 Minutes
every now and then usually they play
Ziggy Stardust that was right and every
now and then they play shoes and parties
and I'd hear rumors that oh no you can
get a whole VHS tape of all I had to
have a whole bunch I had it it's called
shadow of light yeah and they wanted
like 80 90 bucks for that [__] yeah and
that was and first I bought it in New
York actually for a young guy in his
[__] late teens so then you're not
gonna be able to cough up 80 bucks for
that [__] yeah that had all their videos
yeah a lot of them to be fair though
were just like live Clips which a lot of
videos were back then like especially if
you were a band that didn't have like a
[__] ton of money but it did have mask
on it it had spirit and it had because I
think that was the first time I'd seen
the video for spirit I didn't even
realize that had a video yeah they play
a house video or something that was
obscure and it would take you to another
world for as long as you were seeing it
on the damn screen yeah remember then it
was gone it was over mask is my favorite
that was that was a cool I can't believe
I saw that man you said we gotta go
smoke a joint
let's talk about this let's talk about
it yeah that's the way it was like man
it was yeah it was yeah it was like a
lot harder you just had to like wait
around yeah because you know I kind of
grew up you know I didn't have a lot of
money growing up so it's like I couldn't
really afford you know I had to save up
for like months and months if I wanted
to buy like one thing because a lot of
it was important it was super expensive
so you had to order it from overseas and
clothes were uh cool clothes
you'd have to go to [__] New York to
get them you could or later on you could
order them through fanzines
but you were just at that time I was
late teens early 20s you were just
struggling to survive yeah so having a
cool wardrobe
it wasn't going to happen really
a lot of seamsters who were [__]
famous in the scene might have only had
three or four outfits yeah and a lot of
it was cheap stuff that they cut up it
was all self-purp you know ripped up
[__] fishnets and [__] and [__]
Salvage stuff and yeah hand me down we
used to just get stuff from like the
thrift store thrift store they're
getting old stuff from the top it up
finding finding clothes from the 30s and
40s and changing that and then like
you'd go to Kmart or something and get
like just a like a regular
it's a pair of black tights or some [__]
like that you'd have to like alter
everything now you can go on a [__]
Chinese application that I have called
Sheen and for less than 100 bucks get
yourself all decked out basically just
like a whole [__] wardrobe the whole
wardrobe of [__] goth stuff that
would get you through a year of the club
for that for about like a hundred bucks
and you wouldn't even have to wear the
same it's always it's always kind of
good to get
basic
pieces that you can mix and match yeah
you got to have boots and shoes first
and that's where all the money goes
that's what everybody's looking at if
you don't have nice boots and shoes they
know the brands and everything because
the thing about it is that I do have
like a few pieces of clothing that are
like really really cool and like really
really distinctive but the problem with
that is that really you can only wear it
once every few months because you know
it's so distinctive that people are
gonna remember it so I think it's better
if you're just looking for to get a
wardrobe to get like a bunch of that are
cool looking but not like super
distinctive and then that way you can
kind of like mix and match them and
they'll look like different outfits you
know what I'm saying yeah
um let me see
Zach says I saw the music video for
Every Breath You Take and it looked so
awesome with all that high contrast
black and white and [__] stylish as hell
yeah I remember it handles it's no that
was um that was wrapped around that's
right ready to figure this right the one
with your where he's knocking all these
down okay that was the one I was
thinking about Every Breath You Take is
um is actually quite simple I think it's
mostly just Sting's face like close up
and it's just kind of like black and
white and I think it's like a like just
almost like a spotlight kind of effect
if I remember I haven't seen it in a
while but I just heard the song the
other day watch a video for
synchronicity man it's a synchronicity
too or is it just synchronous D1 did
that have a video it's the one you know
yeah
Mad Max [__] he's got his hair spiked
up like [__] um Billy Idol and he's
hanging from the [__] wire and
everything oh that's right oh that's
right yeah yeah yeah okay I remember it
now yeah I just totally blanked on it
now but now that you're bringing it yeah
yeah that's I remember
yeah I think that was synchronicity too
synchronicity two I think is what it was
the one about the Loch Ness monster
the one about the lock that's well
that's just on the side what a weird
album that was well it's funny because I
think that's like I said that's not the
first album I ever heard but
synchronicity by the police was I think
the first album and it was an actual
vinyl album yeah that I bought with my
own money like I bought it when I was
11.
and I played the [__] out of that thing
like I learned all the [__] words and
everything like that but it's like
listening to it now it's almost like a
concept album yeah kinda yeah um but I'm
like it's funny that 11 year old me is
like singing along to this to all this
morning and now that I'm thinking about
I'm like wow this is a weird [__] she's
just some weird [__] it's pretty deep
too it is referencing [__] famous
authors and stuff
I remembered liking ghost in the machine
and
what's this
that's almost kind of like a reggae
album Parts yeah they had a lot of
Reggae particularly early on yeah
but the police were good real good
that's why I [__] would stay I gotta
[__] stick it is lingam and he's
lingam
orous position didn't we say like on the
other on the show the other night that
we were gonna do that we were gonna do
like a parody of that where your dress
up as sting and like yeah I don't know
how I'm gonna do it and then I'll just
like it would be funny if we could do
like some kind of Patrick sex and [__]
right right like if we could do some
kind of special effect where we were
like sitting in the Lotus position and
then you were like floating or something
that that would be super fun and then
you just kind of in sheath yourself
I never when he started going on
tantric sex stuff and everything to me I
was like thinking oh yeah this is kind
of like [__] Steven Seagal and his
[__] breast his breast [__] lump
findings
shiatsu you know right I'm really good
at final Ops you know yeah I'll bet
using shiatsu it's like I'm really good
at finding lumps too bam now there's one
in your [__] head you don't have
anyone you're goddamn yeah shoe polish
hairdo there yeah but you know what I
mean I'm so mean [__] that dude
well he's just such a rich vein of
bullshitery that he's like just so funny
he's fun to talk about makes movies and
he's not in them
and then I need to get on that gig yeah
make a movie and don't you're not here
make a movie like starring me except I'm
not gonna show up yeah but I still want
the paycheck stunt doubles other people
doing voice over for me
yeah just go in there and just pretend
to be me yeah look like me I don't give
a [__] yeah shoot it from the back just
to the back of my head
and then he goes in there and shoots
[__] an hour an hour's worth of work
and then he just kind of [__] edited
in there just like close-ups of his face
sitting there eating a whole dozen
Dunkin Donuts or whatever the [__] he's
doing I haven't been able to get through
any of his modern movies
they're really boring
they're not even like so bad that
they're entertaining they're just really
really dull Under Siege man it's his
best one [__] um under siege two I
liked it uh [__] uh hard to kill that
was a good one
um there was another one that I had that
was pretty good
out for justice I think is what it's
called final Justice inside just final
Justice
was the one with Joe Don Baker okay I
remember what it is some kind of that
was on Mysteries that one was okay
but uh
nah man [__] Under Siege and under
these two
where he's with his cousin making a move
on his own his little cousin
remember that yeah that's right the girl
the girl that well there's a girl he
escorts through the whole thing to
safety and it turns out it's his cousin
but he's definitely [__] hot on his
cousin
it's some weird [__] man then how old is
she
it's just like it's like any other
[__] Steven Seagal movie she's like
19 18 17. something like that it's like
hey we're not that related
I used to think what it was is that they
were I used to think that what they were
doing was kind of like play into the
audience they're like hey it's teenage
boys [__]
oh in the audience probably so we'll put
a hot teenage girl in there that they
can [__] Feast their eyes on and then
they can and then uh Steven Seagal could
just be macho man around her and keep
saving her and these these teenage boys
can pretend that that they are him right
you know
but I don't think that's what it was I'm
reading into I think what it was is it
was just Steven Seagal wanting to
[__] be in a perfect being a Steven
Seagal I wanted to impress teenage girls
on screen that's what it really was I
think yeah I definitely think you're
reading too much into it I was reading
too much into it yeah
no I wanted to be about 18 or 19. yeah
okay all right Steve and then uh
whatever reason yeah she loves me okay
yeah yeah yeah and she loves me even
though we're cousins she still loves me
okay everybody's like yeah yeah wait are
you okay that's like now we're getting
to a very specific fetish that yeah
where you want to bang your cousin yeah
I think that's what's going on that he
wants to bang his cousin he's 19. well I
don't know allegedly that's what it was
on the movie
[Laughter]
this very thing we were talking about
staying just now Mr 88 said sting
bragged about lasting four hours during
sex perhaps he's just really bad at it
and then Zach said legit what is the
point of that see that's what I was
gonna say how does it not get exhausting
and annoying after an hour are you done
yet just imagine the girl looking all
bored flipping through the magazine
while sting is still pounding away
exactly
let's see what's on TV I think he was
sitting there in the Lotus position like
that with his Lincoln rock hard and she
had sacrificed herself upon it like on
an idol and they just sit there thinking
about it warm oh saying arms and [__] oh
that's that thing that's what I think
he's talking that sounds boring as [__]
yeah they're they're [__] um man I'm
just not spiritual they're being Spirits
for any of this [__] [__] I
just you know yeah I remember hearing
that [__] it's a long time ago I forgot
all the details but yeah I'm just here
to get it I remember going I don't want
to lay here for four hours I got [__] to
do you know what I mean I remember even
back in those days as gullible as I was
this guy's full of [__]
well I mean it was almost like bottle
level [__] you know what I mean although
I will say that he's actually just like
trolling and he's just being like like a
snarky [__] than Kudos because that's
pretty [__] funny he's definitely
seems snarky definitely he did he does
so I so I don't
um I don't put him in the same douchery
level uh at the same douchery level as I
would Bono because Bono just definitely
seems very very douchey and very um he
believes his [__] right and very uh
what's the word I'm looking for where he
actually believes his own [__] he's
real [__] um self [__] like very
Earnest is what is the word I was
looking for
um
sting always came across me like he's
just slightly being like sarcastic yeah
you know what I mean so he could just
completely be making all this [__] up
and just thinking it's funny that people
keep like reporting on it which like I
said yeah if he was trolling because he
knew all about trolling he was in
Brimstone and treacle so he's probably
man what a great movie if you guys ever
do that wait have we have you reviewed
that we did didn't we I think we did I'm
pretty sure we did we did yeah
and this is crazy because how we ended
up seeing how I ended up seeing this
movie because I had never seen it
was I had seen Dennis Potter's other
stuff like I had seen um I had read some
of his books and stuff Pennies from
Heaven and um singing detective and all
that
so one day several years ago Tom just
wakes up randomly like one Saturday
morning and he says I was just thinking
about this movie that I saw and he was
like talking about this movie and I was
like what is this movie I never heard I
never saw that and he's like I don't
know I don't remember what it was called
and like he could remember like some
scenes about it but he's like all he
could remember about he's like he's like
man I can't remember anybody's like oh
but sting was in it and I said oh well
that's good that narrows it down yeah so
we went we went to the to the interwebs
and we looked it up and I was like oh
it's Brimstone tree and I was like oh
it's Dennis Potter I was like I've read
some of his um some of his stuff like
his yeah but I had never seen that now
they did a couple different versions of
it because the version of it was Sting
was actually a slightly later version
because it started out as a stage play
and then I think they did it on British
TV for um on uh play for today which was
you know the show that they saw where
they had like you know like stage play
or whatever and they did that but I
think that they banned it after that
because it was like too controversial or
whatever but then like later on they
when did that movie come out 82 83
somewhere around there like it was early
80s but it's it's great it's a weird
story it's a weird story but but sting
is [__] great it plays a demon
basically essentially they never come
out and say he's it's a lot clearer that
he's a demon like in the stage version
like he actually has like cloven Hooves
and stuff but in the movie they leave it
ambiguous as to like what his deal is
and he's a demon that takes he's
supposed to be a demon he's a demon that
takes advantage of your [__] good
nature
he talks his way into your house and
[__]
tries to become part of the family and
tries to offer his services and uh tries
to do things in exchange for saying
there and then just slowly
charms your wife type of deals so she
doesn't want to let him go and he just
tightens the screws down on you and he
tries to take over your whole [__]
life that's
well that's what kind of demon he is
but this particular family has a DOT has
a daughter
who's I guess she's in her late teens
early 20s and she's uh was gotten to a
car wreck when the car wreck car
accident she got hit by a hit by a car
hit by a truck and it uh so she was kind
of like in a vegetative state
and uh
so he's smooching with the wife and
trying to take over the husband's trying
to get rid of the guy but he's powerless
to stop it
and then when they're out of when
they're out of the house he secretly
sneaks in starts molesting the
the bedridden daughter she's out of it
though she's like a vegetable
and um he kind of goes further and
further each time he's less than she is
pretty
and she wouldn't be in real life because
she'd been bedridden for I think for
five six years wasn't it I can't
remember how long it had been she
actually had been totally after it maybe
would have been I think it was only two
years two years okay or something like
that all right she would have been in
bad shape probably but anyway uh she
looked like a model though you know in
the movie well it's a movie it's a movie
and weird [__] happens with this I mean
she
I don't know if I should spoil it you
probably shouldn't because I think a lot
of I think a lot of people have not seen
it yeah I guess it's called Brimstone
Brimstone and treacle yeah it's a
British movie they suck at Dennis Potter
yeah it's it's sucking off the chain
it's good it's a little it's weird I
don't know if I call it nihilistic it's
weird but it's very very morally gray
yeah like a lot of his stuff was I feel
like and a lot of it was very you find
curmudgeonly I think Dennis Potter like
didn't really like humans too much yeah
you find you find [__] out about the dad
he's got secrets and even find out stuff
about the mom and uh just the sting does
a [__] fantastic job yeah he's Duke
and act he's great he's young in this
maybe 20s yeah this was only a few years
after when did Quadrophenia come out
because he was in quadrophenas yeah yeah
and then a couple years after this he
was in The Bride yeah
he could actually
um and he just
I we I remember watching the bride so
many times like when I was because it
was on [__] HBO or whatever like
[__] every five minutes so I must
have seen it like 40 bajillion times but
um Tom had never seen it
so you know a few months back when we
were doing like all the universal
monsters and stuff I'm like oh you got
to see the bride because he'd never seen
it on like stings in it you love him so
uh so we watched it it's like it and it
was like just as good as I remembered
it's a little overwrought but you know
it's the 80s what are you gonna do and
sting was actually great I think he made
a great like Victor Frankenstein he was
like such a [__] he was such a [__]
you know what I mean he was just like
such an [__] but he was just like
really really good at it he was really
good at it and Clancy Brown was in it
too he played the monster
so and it's always good seeing Clancy
Brown in something
uh Ben says when I was little I got
chased out of the living room by my
mother and grandmother because they were
watching some Dennis Potter show and
they didn't want to have to explain it
to me I wonder if it was Prince or to
trickle or like I said it might have
been Pennies from Heaven or the singing
detective I have somewhere in my
what
okay
what's up
she just walks in and it's like I'm like
okay what are you talking about
what are you talking about
I don't know what you're talking about
Pokey
I don't know what she's talking about
she just came in and started yelling at
me yeah she's like asking what's up
she's like hey yeah okay do something
for me You're Gonna Knock Spock over
um
but I actually have somewhere in my
bookshelves I have the um the screenplay
of the singing detective and I saw there
was an adaptation there's been a couple
adaptations of it made I think one of
them had Robert Downey Jr in it now that
I'm thinking about it but um
that's a weird story like it's real
trippy
it kind of like goes back and forth and
time and it's like real I don't know
it's like trippy but it's really really
good and Ben said probably the singing
detective yeah I don't think I would
like to I don't really think I'd like to
explain that to an adult because I'm not
really sure I got an entire handle on it
myself you know what I mean
Oracle said is that a Pookie yes it is
yeah she just it's just funny because
she just like walked in the room and
it's like look yeah right in the eyes
and was like and I was like okay
she's very demanding
I got her um I think Celtic Angel was
here earlier and she's the one that sent
us um sent us all that stuff and then
also sent that Amazon gift card you know
yeah to get yeah so we got Pookie and
beige we got them
um we ordered some [__] for them because
we got them a new uh water fountain
because we have one and it still works
kind of but like I was cleaning it
yesterday and every time we clean it it
seems like the motor is like kind of
getting clogged up and it's like so
every time you clean it it takes longer
and longer for it to like come back on
and I was like maybe I should get
another one like get another was that
Thunder yeah
um maybe I should get another one like
as a backup because I like having water
fountains around for the kitties to
drink out of
because they seem to like the little
fountains you know so I got her a backup
one and I got some filters and I got her
some new
um treats like some shrimpy shrimp and I
got like a big case of
more canned food and so I got so I got
like all kind of stuff for them
I'll hail the mighty pookie
she's uh I was trying to think of didn't
she do something [__] funny the other
day I'm trying to think of like that
funny thing she was doing the other day
but now I can't think of it she does
funny [__] all the time
oh look Misty's with her
we're on the show right now
what's up and say hi Misty
[Laughter]
what you guys doing
yeah
yeah you guys just gotta uh sit around
and uh get drunk outside the house I
mean we'll drink look at their jet there
drinking we're just sitting around
getting we're on the show we're just
sitting around getting we're we're
sitting around getting drunk too yeah
because it's Friday night hey we're on
the show we gotta get back to the show
hahaha
okay say goodbye
it's just white yeah all right they're
kissing okay
it's just White
oh one thing that one thing that Pookie
does because remember like I said how
she likes the um the warm laundry yeah
she knows if you bring the laundry
basket like up the stairs or I think she
knows the word laundry too because last
night Tom was doing his laundry and he
came and dumped it out on the bed and I
said Pookie laundry and like a couple
seconds later she comes up and she like
peeks in the door like she knows where
laundry is she's like and then she ran
up in like yeah got in the file yeah and
she just sits there yeah she climbs into
the pile and then just sits there with
her little face sticking out yeah and if
that laundry's not warm she's depressed
about it she's like but uh if it's warm
I'll pick it up and she'll run around
underneath it I'll drop the whole pile
on her and she loves it too a little
face will come up out of the [__]
laundry
sits there she's like it's hot
funny man it's a funny cat she's a very
funny cat yeah you start shaping things
away to hang him up she's no don't take
it don't don't grab it yet she tries to
stop it no you're taking my pile
I don't understand like how
because she will sleep right in a
Sunbeam
like during like certain time being the
size of a dollar bill she'll go get into
it like certain times of the day like
when the sun is coming in the because I
mean I keep the curtains closed in here
all the time because I like the dark but
in the gym next door
you know in the next room over the
windows are open so like the sun will
come in there
and so she goes in the gym and like lays
against the wall like right in the
Sunbeam I don't know how she can stand
it it's got to be [__] roasting in
there though
I guess it's keeping the heat out I
guess I would I I would hope so because
it's like man she's gonna like the Sun
hits it and it just stays on the surface
of the fur and she's like ooh Warmness I
don't know I don't know we're talking
about cats man but I guess people cats
are popular well yeah why do you always
get upset every time what's funny about
one of the things that's funny about her
is that if if I'm on a floor or if I'm
up in a man cave and I've got a tablet
and I put the tablet down she's got to
get next to the tablet like it's a fire
to stay warm she slowly looks at the
tablet and then she tries to get on top
of the tablet and of course it stops the
video like stop it and I'll even put it
up high and she'll try to get up there
and look at the tablet
so watch it and there's lights so she
likes to get around the little rgbs and
stuff yeah
I don't know what it is about tablets
and the fact that they light up
yeah it's light do you want to try to
curl up on the light because we have in
the bedroom we have one of those
um what is it called like a bliss light
or whatever it's called yeah that makes
like um like a Galaxy like on the
ceiling and for a while we had it like
on this shelf like Acro like on the
other side of the room and like casting
up on and she would jump up on the on
the shelf or on the bookshelf and just
like kind of sit by it yeah like and I
don't know why she's so into it but she
really likes [__] that lights up she
wants to be near a light yeah which I
don't because there's something
happening I guess we were thinking about
because I was like maybe I
this is hilarious but I looked on Amazon
I said does anybody make
tablets for cats you know what I mean
like a computer tablet like obviously it
wouldn't be a real tablet a real tablet
but just like some but like a tablet
that was like just some kind of
simplified thing that just had like a
couple games on it or like little fishy
swimming around or something
um I don't think they have any
specifically for cats but there were a
couple like for babies like or toddlers
that would probably work for a cat you
know what I mean because they were kind
of you know durable like because they
knew the toddler would be like drooling
on it throwing around and [__] and um
and it just had like a couple little
simple
games and [__] like that on it like you
know because it's not mine
see I think that's the thing like I
would probably because I was thinking to
myself the same thing I was thinking
like I would spend money and get it for
her and be like hey pookie look your own
tablet and she'd be like man Jesus
that's not yours that's not yours I want
to [__] with your [__] yeah exactly if
you give her her own [__] she's just
like I don't want it
I think part of it is the competition
for attention she knows you're looking
in that tablet and she doesn't want you
to look in that town yeah she's like her
right so the tablet she knows the tablet
is something you look at that's like her
competition
look at it too and she doesn't want me
to look at it it's a competition for the
tablet yeah I think it's what it is
because you said she doesn't quite
understand it right
you know
doesn't understand the flow of
information and she can't hear that I
got earbuds on so she can't hear what's
happening she's just seeing little
people talking
like little stuff
little faces I know that they do have
like apps or like little games for cats
like I said that have like little
fishies or little things like swimming
around like going in so they can like
try and get them and some cats like
apparently really like them but I never
tried them with her but says see that's
the thing we tried this before because
Pookie has a thing where
Tom has you know the the little webcam
deal on his tablet like he hasn't
covered up with a piece of tape
and for whatever reason she loves that
piece of tape and she just always if he
leaves it laying around the first thing
she'll jump up and try to like pull that
piece of tape off like with her mouth
so Tom had an old tablet that didn't
work anymore and he put little pieces of
tape all over it and gave it to her and
she didn't give a [__] she just wants to
pull the tape off of your tablet yeah
she didn't want to pull the tape off the
one that we gave her
yeah so yeah it was funny those are my
tablets too I just don't use them
anymore they're not good enough though
they're not the one that I'm using
and I put a lot of tape on it and she's
like nope
that's fake that's a fake tablet well
see I think a lot of people that have
cats they say the same thing it's like
oh we bought him this really expensive
like scratching posters really expensive
toy or something like that and all they
want to do is play in the box that it
came in yeah you know what I mean I
think a lot of little kids are like that
too like they're more interested in like
the box or the paper
and [__] like that she loves that kind
of [__] she loves boxes and all that
kind of crap but you know
um let me see people are saying hi to
Misty yeah
yeah they're like I said they're in a
different time zone because they're
they're in Texas right yeah how many
hours earlier a couple hours is two
hours a couple hours yeah
is that Central time or mountain time I
think it's probably Central Time El Paso
yeah where's El Paso that's El Paso
Central or yeah I think that I think El
Paso is almost near like New Mexico and
everything in it
uh that's like West Texas I don't know
I've never been to Texas Texas Biggs
twice the size of Germany I've been in
New Mexico but I've never been to Texas
before you know what I mean I've been in
New Mexico and I've been to Colorado but
I've never been to Texas
so you know
uh Ben says we're talking about Steven
Seagal earlier Steven Seagal did stand
up against the mafia shaking down his
production and gave evidence against
them the only admirable thing I think
he's ever done never heard of that one I
never heard of that either actually
uh Victor says El Paso is Mountain Time
the rest of the state is Central okay
all right uh Mr 88 said Texas is one
hour behind Florida I thought it was two
hours but I didn't know what I mean like
I don't you know
we are Eastern Standard Time so it's 905
p.m where we are so you know
that's what's going on there's still
light over there
yeah so yeah I just saw him and it's
light they're on their back porch drink
it
they're trying to get us on a cam
yeah those perverts
it is Friday night it depends it depends
on how drunk we get but you know what I
mean
man we'll see yeah we'll see
see after it goes
it's kind of sleeping
yeah yeah I mean I get well you were
awake when I got up yeah and I went back
to sleep for a little while
I got up and I was like don't go
I was like I got you though yeah
yeah
because I woke up at five I always wake
up at five yeah or a little bit before
actually I woke up at
4 15.
and then I was like uh he's like [__] I
hate when I do that if I'm gonna wake up
in the middle of the night I actually I
know this is weird I don't know if other
people do this too but if I have to get
up early to go to work or something like
that I always kind of like to wake up
in the middle of the night because
it for some reason it makes the night
seem longer
because here's the thing I'm always just
kind of like look if you just fell
asleep at 10 or 11 o'clock and then you
woke up for work at five or six or
whatever time you get up for work
um you know it would just seem like you
you know it was just like a second
because you know you're asleep so you
don't really like realize the passage of
time but if you wake up in the middle of
the night like at two or three in the
morning
then you're like you're actually like
can wake up and then you'd be like oh
[__] it's time to get up oh no it's not
and I really like that feeling I know
that's really weird but I really like
that feeling of oh [__] I have to get up
to go to work but then you roll over and
you could still have like two or three
hours to sleep and that's I love that
feeling that's like awesome
so sometimes for a while I was like
almost making myself wake up
deliberately like in the middle of the
night but as it is now I kind of wake up
the shitty thing is I usually try and
fall asleep like
at 10 or 11. like last night I think I
fell asleep about 10 30. like I was up
and I was watching um
uh uh like I don't know we did like a
couple things and then
I was watching a couple episodes of um
base Motel and then um I was like it was
getting to be like 10 10 30 and I was
like yeah I gotta I really gotta go to
sleep so I think I fell asleep then but
I think I woke up at 4 15 and I hate
when that happens because if I wake up
at 4 15 I'm always like
it's not enough time like to go back to
sleep because I have to get up at five
you know what I mean so it's always kind
of like
if I'm gonna wake up in the middle of
the night I think I'd rather wake up at
like one or two because then I'd be like
woohoo I have like a bunch more hours
and I can go to sleep if it's 4 15 I'm
just like if I fall back to sleep now
I'm gonna oversleep and then I'll wake
up and it'll be like and I'll be late
you know
so I always kind of hate that but I
always wake and then I'm just like so I
can't go back to sleep and then I don't
really want to get up so then I'm just
kind of laying there in this like
[__] weird limbo you know what I mean
Zach says um
I hate when that happens because when
I'm thinking then I'm thinking about
work especially if I don't like my job
and then I can't sleep yeah I mean I
know what that I know but
I don't know why it's just I'm weird
like that if I have to get up early I
really really like the feeling of waking
up thinking it's time to get up to go to
work and then you look at the clock and
it's only like two in the morning and
you're like yeah I can go back to sleep
for like four hours or whatever I really
like that feeling you know what I mean
yeah so sometimes I do it deliberately
but like I said this morning I woke up
like 45 minutes before and I was like
well that's not enough time so that's
shitty when that happens there has to be
at least there it has to be at least two
hours earlier because then I'm like oh I
have two whole hours if it's an hour or
less then it's not worth it then I'm
just mad
because then I just have to lay there
and I'm like I don't really want to get
up but I can't really get back to sleep
either because if I go back to sleep
I'll over sleep
you know because I have had that happen
a couple times but I didn't I don't um I
don't have an alarm clock or anything
like that because I don't need it
I usually I always always wake up
on time
whether I'm watching or not well it's
nine do you want to go ahead and end the
show
I reckon yeah all right you worked all
day yeah I do have to unwind yeah I'm
all wound up yes
[Laughter]
all right well go ahead and close it out
Jim all right well there was one more
thing uh all right what was I gonna say
no I forgot what it was
but um yeah don't worry about it you
talk about it later
was it an announcement
um I don't well I don't remember because
I don't remember what it was I don't
remember what it was okay
you threw me off it couldn't have been
that important
oh I'm sure it wasn't we're not talking
about a topic I'm not talking about a
topic I'm sure and it's what it it we
try to we're trying to uh I remember
what it was okay I was gonna say that we
would be back on Sunday doing a movie
review there's a plug and we're gonna do
the professional yeah yeah because
xanadas sent us that right yeah and that
was that's the one that we haven't
watched yet yeah so we want to see the
French version the French well yeah
we're gonna watch that one so I think
it's actually called Leon the
Professional yeah you know what I mean
like I've seen it called both things but
we're just gonna call it the
professional just be
all right so thank you everybody for
hanging out with us this evening uh
hopefully you have a good start to your
weekend and we will see you guys again
on Sunday for the movie review uh we'll
probably do it at 6 p.m Eastern Standard
Time just because it's earlier when we
you know I'm not at work so we can do it
earlier uh so yeah we'll see you guys
then thank you very much for hanging out
with us and we'll see you later good
night